okay we have to talk about yesterday's
cabinet meeting Donald Trump had a
cabinet meeting in front of the cameras
yesterday the president's cabinet is a
very important organization entity it's
part of the executive branch there are
23 members plus the vice-president 15
principal officers seven other members
Trump is the chairman of the cabinet the
cabinet is a really big deal and
yesterday's cabinet meeting was a
veritable house of horrors freak show
and I would be doing everybody a
disservice if I pretended that this
didn't go down so this is going to be a
little painful but come along with me we
are going to spend some time today going
through some of what took place
yesterday
starting with what was a completely
insane moment Donald Trump was asked
given that minority communities are
disproportionately affected by
coronavirus what specifically are you
doing for them Trump didn't answer and
at one point Trump essentially listed
races and ethnicities take a look at
this president you continue to talk
about helping minority communities what
specifically are you looking at to help
those communities what actions so one of
the things I was most proud of was the
minority community and all of the work
we've done for the minority communities
black unemployment Hispanic unemployment
Asian unemployment was the best ever in
the history of our country we've never
had anything like it we've never had so
many african-american jobs ever ever in
the history of our country by far and we
are bringing our country back and a big
focus is exactly that with the
minorities specifically if you look at
the Asians they've done incredibly well
Hispanics incredibly well
african-americans record-setting every
month you know that every month it was a
record-setting jobs number yes black
Hispanic Asian those certainly exist
that's true but it's not an answer and
by the end of this two-minute answer
which I'm not going to subject you to in
total Donald Trump was talking about
completely unrelated things like
ventilators at one point now people
often ask why don't the press call Trump
out and say you're
not answering the question you're not
answering the question the format makes
it difficult Trump will just move on to
the next person the microphone gets
moved he'll call the reporter following
up you know a nasty person or call it a
nasty question he actually does that a
little bit later today and if you
actually do get to press Trump on a
follow-up he'll just tell three more
lies and it genuinely is pretty
difficult now of course the topic of
hydroxychloroquine came up the day
before yesterday Donald Trump claimed
that he's been taking hydroxychloroquine
prophylactically for weeks and Donald
Trump claims that the best randomized
controlled trial that we have about
hydroxy chloro chloroquine is a fake
false study there was a study done where
they gave it to very sick people
extremely sick people people that were
ready to die it was given by obviously
not friends of the administration and
the study came out the people were ready
to die
everybody was old had bad problems with
hearts diabetes and everything else you
can imagine so they gave it so
immediately when it came out they gave a
lot of false information just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right so it's true
it was given to people sick enough to
already be in the hospital that is true
but it was not a fake false study it was
a proper study it had a placebo group it
had randomization it's the best study we
have so far now let me go back to just
that last moment of trumps answer
briefly Trump does seem to forget what
the drug is called there he seems to
glitch he says hydroxy and then he has
this vacant look in his eyes he seems to
forget what he's talking about fumbles
to recover and asks the reporter if they
know what he's talking about take a look
at that moment again and just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right
great studies came out really strange
stuff for short from falling apart
completely now one more glitch here
Trump said something about
DOCSIS I I guess he was trying to say
doctor here ourselves many many doctors
doctors many doctors came out and they
said it's great now you have to go to a
doc okay so that one doesn't need too
much more discussion and then lastly on
hydroxychloroquine here is Trump saying
that hydroxychloroquine doesn't harm
anyone which is untrue there are people
who have been harmed by taking this
medication is true one way or the other
way that you like it or not it's been
around for 70 years unbelievably
effective for malaria and for lupus and
probably effective for arthritis and
what has been determined is it doesn't
harm you it's a very powerful drug I
guess but it doesn't harm you and so I
thought as a frontline defense possibly
it would be good and I've had no impact
from it I've had no I feel the same I
haven't changed I don't think too much
and at some point you know I won't take
it might be soon might be a little bit
it doesn't it doesn't seem to have any
impact on me but it seems to be a extra
line of defense and it's gotten
tremendous reviews from some people he's
not a different person as a result of
taking the drug that's good to know
now here's a really odd moment Treasury
Secretary Stephen minuchin announced
they're going to be sending out debit
cards to people with stimulus money
instead of checks or direct deposits in
some cases and he actually takes out and
presents a debit card to Trump with
Trump's name on it and he seems to be
explaining to Trump how debit cards work
which actually is not super surprising a
debit card looks like with your name on
it mr. president now there's no money
for you on it this is a blank debit card
but I want you to see what many
Americans will now get so that we could
get their money to them even quicker and
going forward we think debit cards are a
safe and secure way of delivering
refunds so I shine the letter again
Steve's had a great career now it is
quite possible that Donald Trump doesn't
no no how debit cards work he's been a
rich guy his whole life he may not
understand how a debit card works but my
question is whether this is actually a
good idea if you send someone a debit
card how do you pay rent with that how
do you pay your mortgage with that you
often can't pay those with a debit card
and when you do you sometimes pay three
four five even six percent in fees so it
seems like a strange idea to me quite
frankly we certainly need to learn more
about it and then here is Donald Trump
once again calling a female reporter
rude and telling her that's enough of
you when she tries to follow up go ahead
mr. president why haven't you announced
a plan to get 36 million unemployed
Americans back to work you're overseeing
historic economic despair I think we've
announced a plan we're opening up our
country just a rude person you are we're
opening up our country and we're opening
it up very fast the plan is that each
state is opening and it's opening up
very effectively and when you see the
numbers I think even you will be
impressed which is pretty hard to
impress you yeah go ahead and then very
last thing this is a bonus from earlier
in the day this was before Trump's
cabinet meeting Trump was asked about
Nancy Pelosi's comments about him the
day before that as a morbidly obese man
as she put it Donald Trump should not be
taking hydroxychloroquine and here's how
Trump reacted these people are sick
Pelosi is a sick woman she's got a lot
of problems a lot of mental problems
we're dealing with people that have to
get their act together for the good of
the country okay so there it is a 73
year old rich guy who literally wears
orange clown makeup says that Nancy
Pelosi is the one who is mentally sick
so these events are seen around the
world the civilized world can't believe
that this is what's happening here we
are the laughingstock and as I told you
earlier this week we are increasingly
pitied by the world because this is the
guy who's running the show people see
this people see this and even if a
trumpet thinks this is great what a
great from taking Hyde
Roxi chloroquine and calling out
reporters for nasty questions and all of
the stuff the world sees it they laugh
and they pity us and it's a really major
embarrassment it's a national nightmare
that we'd really need to end and we have
the opportunity to end it just over five
months from now check this out the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video